legendary actor bill murray in renown
tell us john vogler so one night in 2018
murray joined a quartet featuring vogler
for a concert at a nearly 2 000 year old
theater in greece the performance
included poetry recital readings and
songs from ranging from bach to bruce
hornsby it was captured for a new
concert film new worlds the cradle of
civilization here are just a few amazing
moments well we put some chairs in this
stuff is
it's junk what we're doing it's not good
if you want to go completely understand
there are divine things
well enveloped
the piano
has been drinking
[Music]
[Applause]
the things that you're liable to read in
the bible it is
[Music]
[Applause]
nice bill murray and john vogler joins
us right now first on cbs mornings good
morning how are you guys doing uh good
nate how are you doing good we're great
morning so bill um how did this
show idea come about
well he's very ambitious i am not and
he's a he's a thinker he gets a lot done
while i'm asleep
it was all jan's idea john was it really
all your idea but didn't you guys meet
at an airport is that how is that how
this bromance started at an airport
that's true it was berlin airport my
hometown and uh i was boarding the
flight and little tapped on my shoulder
and said what are you going to do with
this big box he saw my cello and on the
plane you're going to fit that thing in
the overhead oh so you started the
conversation damaged and uh said no it
has its own seat now bill the rest of
the quartet is in the green room what
was it like to work with such a talented
trio
well um you know kind of like you feel
you let them do all the heavy lifting
and you're just sort of skating that's
right
how'd you know man you're not training
behind me wait my strategy man
all right i can see things i know what's
going on
john when you got the shoulder tap from
him in the berlin airport did you know
this was bill murray who was shoulder
tapping you
well you know i'm always ashamed to say
not immediately it was you're in your
zone on the airport when you bought a
plane but then when we sat next to each
other on the plane that was a big
coincidence
and so it's a long flight too yeah and
he was very surprised that he didn't
know but
one of my movies was on the plane and it
was like i could feel this german double
take-out
which movie wasn't it that is the mind
tribes stripes stripes it was the first
time i saw the film and it was a
wonderful film i watched it right having
him sit next to me i watched the whole
film and then i said
sir that's a wonderful film this is good
coming up this is really funny
is that what he did yeah i think that's
such a cool way i never meet people like
that never meet a world renowned
anything when i'm traveling on a plane
but i love that this too this friendship
now has bloomed into this to this
musical piece that we get to see i'm
curious bill about how you describe your
singing style because you're singing
you're talking the music of course is
glorious how do you describe your
singing style uh i would call it
unafraid and unaware unafraid
unafraid i have a lot of i have a lot of
faith that uh you know
i got here
so what could possibly happen it's
different every night it comes out
differently every night i don't sing
like ordinary singers do so and that
comes across like oh he's just a young
kid trying you know it's like that you
know they feel i mean but whose idea was
it to do this particular piece of work
john because it's your two worlds are so
very different
well i uh we met at my house and i had a
pile of books and a list of music and i
wanted to fill out what bill likes and
we like the same kind of music it was
amazing and uh he came up with
some
pop music
ideas and so we really have many genres
it's not just classical music and and
then we really had fun to put it
together and bill has a great sense of
drama so how to design the show where to
pull the tension and then the grand
finales bernstein so we had fun putting
it together already and we knew each
other for four years when we started
working together
if if a person is lucky enough to live a
long life it can be a very strange life
full of lots of different chapters
do you find it i'm talking about talking
to me i'm talking to you
and and my future self i hope is it is
it weird to you that you're a guy who
can tap another guy on the shoulder at
an airport and then say you want to do
this weird project and someone says sure
let's do it and then it exists
uh
yeah well i guess so i guess i'm kind of
lucky i've been getting in trouble for a
long time but i've been poking like
girls with pigtails when i was a little
kid but now i'm just poking guys with
that kind of hair so it's uh
um
i was just for i was just curious you
know that's probably what made it happen
i was curious about his box you know
and uh i thought is he going to get away
with this thing getting this thing on
the plane
but
you know he's just uh it's just one of
those nice collisions you know if you're
if you collide with people things have
you know new york is a great place or or
the brilliant airport but it's a great
place to collide with people that's why
i like new york does it surprise you
that people say yes when you come up
with a crazy idea like this it wasn't my
idea it was this idea don't blame me for
this thing
it's a really wonderful show i realized
he said yeah believe me if i could take
the credit i'd get away i'd try to get
away with it but yeah people know bill
uh tony mentioned
growing older and there are some
readings on growing older and the power
of nature and pretty powerful spots
stuff introspective pieces
soul-searching ideas what do you want
people to know about um some of those
moments in this film
well i would say that um this this music
you know a lot of classical music and
these readings american writers great
american writers and poets
that this
that
many of these people have died and
passed away and i think nowadays people
kind of don't know where to look for
like who's who knows what's going on who
can tell me something about something
right and these people
these riders and these composers they're
still alive even though their bodies are
gone right they're still alive because
their music is here and their words are
here and when people see the show they
you can see it you can see it hit them
in the chest you can see them you can
see them affected by the words and the
emotions and the and the ideas expected
it is a visceral thing i mean i think we
could call you bill murray a renaissance
man from caddyshack to groundhog day to
do i dare call you a music maven
do i dare you yes i don't scale you got
a lot of good ideas and and jan did it
change the way you look at classical
music working with him absolutely that's
it so great remark uh
we reached such a wide audience with
this show we played you know carnegie
hall of course and sydney opera house
but also the wilton in los angeles or
chicago theater where never classically
musicians ever set foot before so we
really had great um great experience to
bring this to people and i feel now that
classical music is just like any other
music just good music and i want to
bring it to people who chose greece
because it's so beautiful yeah
uh i think
alexander's dad chose greece i don't
know
it's uh i don't know whose idea that was
but it worked out really nice it did and
you know when you're when you're playing
in front of this people think you're
really good yes
the setting does a lot to be good like
the room they got what did you say
afraid what did you say unaware and
unafraid you're singing underwear that's
how we should always be nicely done
gentlemen we appreciate you guys you
guys are truly the great in your fields
yeah thank you so much for joining us
this morning thank you thank you very
much did you have a good time thanks for
waking us up
okay no i don't represent it the cradle
of civilization opens in theaters
nationwide on february 2nd groundhog
what a coinkydink
groundhog day you heard of that